[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 le journal
voici les titres focus sur la primaire
de la droite et du centre à quelques
jours du vote alain juppé nicolas
sarkozy serait des deux grands favoris
mais françois fillon referais son retard
pour les républicains l'enjeu reste
avant tout la participation
le point dans cette édition nous irons
également à bois d'arcy la ville
inaugure demain buste d'alberto santos
du monde pionnier de l'aviation à cette
occasion la ville propose au sein de sa
mairie une exposition retraçant
l'histoire de l'aviateur brésil est un
pur retour sur le festival play for
humanity à la verrière quatre jours de
concerts et d'événements culturels pour
rendre hommage aux victimes du
terrorisme
mais on débute ce journal avec la venue
de françois hollande aux mureaux
aujourd'hui la poser la première pierre
de la future usine d'intégration pour
ariane 6 sur le site d'airbus safran
launcher le président de la république
qui devrait annoncer sa décision de se
déclarer ou non à l'élection
présidentielle au mois de décembre
prochain au plus bas dans les sondages
il ne récolte que 8 % d'intentions de
vote à la question serait-il un bon
candidat pour la gauche contre 15% pour
emmanuel hogg macron et 21% pour jean
luc mélenchon et manuel valls son
premier ministre on passe à la primaire
de la droite et du centre dernière ligne
droite pour les candidats dimanche 20
novembre aura lieu le premier tour de
l'élection à six jours du vote selon les
sondages alain juppé et nicolas sarkozy
seraient les deux grands favoris
faisons un point avec nicolas landry
20% d'intentions de vote pour françois
fillon derrière alain juppé crédité de
36% et nicolas sarkozy à 26% ce serait
la hiérarchie du premier tour selon le
dernier sondage aux docks ça en
attendant le dernier débat entre les
huit candidats ce jeudi 17 novembre les
responsables yvelinois de la primaire
attendent une mobilisation importante
avec un impact des élections américaines
s'étaient fait aux états unis d'internet
à certains s'en disant ben oui les
sondages donnent alain juppé 1er 2e
sarkozy mais pourquoi pas aller voter
pour peut-être changer la donne on l'a
entendu encore ce week end sur les
marchés où les gens ont dit mais ça va
nous mobiliser peut-être encore plus
pour montrer que
la personne qui peut être dans leur
coeur était en 3 ou 4e position d'un
risque peut-être de passer en seconde
position il ya énormément d'attentes au
niveau du peuple français et je crois
qu'on a véritablement une alternance le
rapporté qu on pourrait être surpris par
le taux de participation
dernière ligne droite pour les
préparatifs du 1er tour avec 264 bureaux
de vote dans les yvelines en milieu
rural on regroupe bien entendu les
villages pour dans un seul et même
bureau donc il peut y avoir quatre cinq
villages regroupés et il y a des
affichettes qui seront installés apposé
sur la porte d'entrée de chacune de ces
mairies dans lesquelles il n'y a pas de
bureaux de vote pour que les électeurs
puissent le le savoir facilement les
résultats c'est une originalité remonte
directement à la haute autorité
c'est à dire qu'il n'y aura pas de
résultats le soir commune par commune au
département par département c'est la
haute autorité qui centralise tous les
résultats les bureaux de vote seront
ouverts dès 8 heures ce dimanche 20
novembre pour une fermeture prévue à 19h
si un jour je suis élu président de la
république je resterai le château de
versailles cette touche d'humour à
l'égard de nos responsables politiques
est signée jean michel aphatie mercredi
sur le plateau de public sénat des
propos qui ont fortement agacé le maire
de versailles françois de mazières et
son adjoint françois xavier bellamy ils
ont tous deux répondu via twitter pour
le maire adjoint je cite détruire
versailles pour compte qu'on cesse
d'aimer la france a pâti dit toute la
folie de la haine contre l'héritage
ambiance vendredi samedi dernier s'est
déroulé le festival play for humanity à
la verrière l'événement a permis de
rendre hommage aux victimes du
terrorisme plusieurs têtes d'affiché
étaient sur place reportage de camille
lambert
[Musique]
ambiances festives sur de la musique
rock pour rendre hommage aux victimes du
terrorisme les fatals picards ont
participé à l'événement play for
humanity ce vendredi 11 novembre à la
salle du scarabée de la verrière un
concert particulier pour les membres du
groupe touchée par les attentats du 13
novembre 2015 il note bassiste et nono
qui s'occupe du plateau était dans la
salle avec nathalie aussi qu'ils
faisaient nos lumières mais qui est
malheureusement décédé au bataclan et
donc du coup c'est pour ça que genre ce
truc est une sorte de résonance un petit
peu funeste pour équipement soit on va
jouer avec une pensée particulière poil
mais mais mais voilà c'est tous les
jours qu'on y pense
[Musique]
il
pour nous chaque concert un moyen de
rappeler certaines valeurs qu'on défend
qui correspondent pas tout à fait à
celle que défend des les personnes qui
se sont permis d'assister du zèle en
voilà au bataclan aux côtés des fatals
picards le groupe n'a elle bande les
membres incarnent des personnages de
jeux de rôle et mélangent musique
médiévale et celtique avec un style rock
le mâle bande c'est un peu un groupe de
musique traditionnelle qui se comporte
comme un groupe de métal sur fun c'est
un peu je pense que c'est un peu le
concept c'est très chaotique c'est
n'importe quoi la distorsion en moins
par contre là il a le solo en défaut
banjo et la fugue op il fallait connaît
[Musique]
je veux
on pense que la culture le sens de la
fête le sens du partage c'est quand même
beaucoup plus important la musique mais
il a l'art de sous toutes ses formes
c'est ce qui permet de progresser dans
nos civilisations les bénéfices seront
reversés au profit de l'association
française des victimes du terrorisme
[Applaudissements]
autre commémoration ce week end le 11
novembre
1918 date de l'armistice annonçant la
fin de la première guerre mondiale à
elancourt les habitants sont venus
nombreux pour suivre la cérémonie animée
par le maire reportage d'anne leur
langue
cent ans après la grande guerre il ne
reste plus aucun combattant survivant
pourtant l'émotion des commémorations
reste intacte comme ici dans la ville
d'elancourt ou des élèves de cm2 ont
rendu hommage aux poilus à travers la
lecture de leur mémoire
larry
david d'inscrits ce qui est des cours il
y avait là dans le fossé deux ans après
sans dommage certains se tenait la
gauche par baudouin iv telle pas encore
été en fait il y en avait qui ils ont
travaillé en fait avec notamment les
ipad les nouveaux outils dont ils ont
fait leurs propres recherches et on a
regardé ça ensemble et chaque groupe a
pu travailler vraiment sur une partie
spécifique de cette fameuse guerre et
puis là le devoir de mémoire pour voir
qu'en fait la liberté elle se paye aussi
au prix du sang elancourt avait perdu
onze de ses hommes pendant le conflit
mais l'hommage de vendredi ne
s'adressait pas seulement aux victimes
de la première guerre mondiale beaucoup
dans l'assemblée penser à fabien jacques
le militaire trappistes tués au mali il
y a dix jours on a
bien sûr plusieurs soldats ici qui ont
participé aux opérations qui sont morts
pour défendre nos libertés il faut le
rappeler c'est ça aussi la solidarité 17
millions de morts pour la première
guerre mondiale 40 à 60 pour la seconde
des chiffres vertigineux qui nous
rappelle chaque année que la paix a été
obtenue à grands frais
bois-d'arcy inaugure demain buste
d'alberto santos dumont un pionnier de
l'aviation
à cette occasion la ville propose au
sein de la mairie une exposition
retraçant l'histoire de l'aviateur
brésilien reportage de mélanie poker
[Musique]
le musée de l'air et de l'espace du
bourget la présente comme simple les
jallet sur la demoiselle est une
invention d'alberto santos dumont
l'aviateur brésilien est mis à l'honneur
à bois d'arcy l'a fait des essais
pendant à peu près trois ans sur la
ville de bonnart 6
sur un terrain d'ailleurs qui partait de
son hangar qui se trouvait sur la
commune de bois d'arcy mais qu'y aller
beaucoup plus loin puisqu'il allait
jusqu'à saint cyr l'école il reste rien
de matériel de du passage de santos
dumont parce que ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est qu'à l'époque il avait un hangar
en bois bien évidemment les hangars a
disparu aujourd'hui il se trouverait à
peu près là où se trouve le centre de
contrôle du centre leclerc à bois d'arcy
concepteur et pilote il battra plusieurs
records dont celui de bagatelle en 1906
avec 1 14 bis il franchira de 120 mètres
à travers archives et maquettes
l'exposition vous plonge dans l'histoire
de cet inventeur c'est notamment le
créateur de la montre-bracelet puisque
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que au début
du siècle les aviateurs avaient des
mondes démontre bout c'est me les montre
gousset en avion c'est pas très pratique
donc il avait demandé à son ami louis
cartier pour ne pas faire de publicité
de lui faire une mousse nous montre
bracelet qui est en fait donc
on lui attribue cette invention dont
cadeaux par cette commande en marge de
cette exposition une stèle commémorative
vient d'être dévoilée sur la commune
on referme ce journal avec la braderie
organisée ce week end au golf national
l'occasion pour les fans de chiner et de
s'équiper à petit prix pour l'hiver
écoutez à ce propos l'une des
responsables sur l'événement maintenant
on fait un tel succès qu'on achète
également des produits donc pas des
produits d'il ya dix ans des produits de
l'année tout simplement en prenant des
gros volumes on arrive à avoir des prix
très intéressants et voilà on souhaite
en faire profiter tous nos clients donc
le textile marché très bien puisque
comme je vous le disais en fait on monte
des grosses opérations avec des très
grandes marques de textiles de c'est
donc le textile giran numéro un après
les clubs marche également très bien et
ensuite tous les accessoires de golf ça
va de la montre gps haute et d'émettre
au balo sac chariot
et c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal
prochaine édition demain à 18 heures
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]